Denise Richards burst onto the scene with a steamy
kiss in "Wild Things" — but it wouldn't be the
last time she attracted attention! From late-'90s
"It" girl to OnlyFans star, the Real Housewife
has always managed to keep things interesting.
In 1998, Denise Richards starred in the sleazy
classic "Wild Things." Her three-way kiss with
Neve Campbell and Matt Dillon was a prominent
draw for audiences, but the film holds other
twists and delights besides all the smooching.
Richards played Kelly Van Ryan in the film, a
wealthy and popular girl who accuses guidance
counselor Sam Lombardo of statutory rape. The two
girls admit to falsifying their accusations on
the stand, which prompts Lombardo to sue Kelly's
family for a significant chunk of change. From
there, things get twistier and twistier. Everyone
is an accomplice on the grift, and everyone
backstabs everyone else. It's high melodrama.
In 1999, Denise Richards co-starred opposite
Kirstie Alley in "Drop Dead Gorgeous." The
deadpan mockumentary was about a small-town
beauty pageant and the series of horrific
murders committed in pursuit of its crown.
The film is now considered a cult classic
but was underseen upon initial release.
Richards played Becky Leeman, the presumed
favorite in the teen beauty pageant contest.
"Oh, my god. Lights, camera and
me without a stitch of makeup on."
Unfortunately for Richards, 1999 was also
the year she co-starred in "The World is
Not Enough," starring Pierce Brosnan
as James Bond. Richards played nuclear
physicist Christmas Jones in the film,
but her role was universally panned by
critics. Yahoo!'s James Bond blog even
had this to say about Richards' part:
"Look up any poll or column from recent
years on the worst Bond girls ever,
and Dr. Christmas Jones comes up every time."
Dr. Christmas Jones came to represent all the
cheese that made Bond fans
sour on the Brosnan films.
"I thought Christmas only comes once a year."
So, in a way, Denise Richards
is partially to thank for the
grittier Daniel Craig version of the character.
During the 2000s and early 2010s, Denise
Richards' film career kind of puttered out.
Her biggest roles post-Bond were mostly cameos in
prominent films. People remember her 10 seconds
in "Love Actually" better than her starring role
in "Deep in the Valley." At the very end of the
Christmas classic, Richards' character travels
to England to meet sad sack Colin's best friend.
However, one of her most memorable guest
appearances was on a controversial seventh
season episode of "Friends," in
which she played Cassie Gellar.
This episode crossed a major line for
many "Friends" fans when Ross tried
to kiss Cassie. Ross even had this
lame explanation for his actions:
"I haven't had sex in a very long time."
Grantland's Sam Hockley-Smith even cites
the episode as the one where
the show jumped the shark.
In 2002, Richards married Charlie Sheen. Their
courtship started normally enough, but things took
a turn shortly after Richards became pregnant
with the couple's second daughter, Lola Rose
Sheen. In 2005, Richards separated from Sheen,
while she was still pregnant with Lola. She later
sought a restraining order against him, citing
threats he'd allegedly made against her life.
Richards found ways to parlay her fracturing
personal life into work by starring in the
reality show "Denise Richards: It's Complicated"
in 2008 and publishing her memoir in 2011.
In the memoir, she talks about Sheen's sudden
transformation into someone she did not trust.
"Yeah, I am on a drug, it's called Charlie Sheen!"
She told the Huffington Post,
"The man I fell in love with
is very compassionate, humble,
has a wonderful heart. And the behavior that
a lot of us saw in the last six months is not
the person that I met and fell in love with."
In 2018, Richards joined the cast of the "The Real
Housewives of Beverly Hills." Richards
was on all of season 9 but left season
10 prematurely after Brandi Glanville
asserted that the two had hooked up.
When Richards refused to return for Season
11, no one was very surprised. The show's
executive producer Andy Cohen told People the
negotiations broke down over pay, but Richards
said that she wanted to spend time with people
that actually liked her. A source told People:
"She was looking to replace RHOBH
with time loving her amazing husband,
children and who knows, maybe even friends now."
In addition to her acting career, Denise
Richards is also an accomplished model.
She started modeling as a teenager and was
successful enough to travel the world for
photoshoots and commercials. Once her acting
career took off, she spent less time modeling,
but still made time to pose in the Gala
Christmas issue of "Playboy" magazine in 2004.
Richards had given birth to her oldest daughter,
Sami, just months before the photoshoot.
Her husband at the time, Charlie Sheen,
was a "Playboy" fan and encouraged
her to be in the magazine — but she
had her own reasons for doing it as well.
Richards revealed to Us Weekly in 2011:
"I wanted to encourage women that it's OK to
embrace your sexuality even though you're a mom."
Richards has gone through so many highs and lows
that it's hard to keep up with it all. Luckily
for her fans, she released her memoir "The Real
Girl Next Door," which ended up becoming a New
York Times bestseller. The book dives into topics
like her tumultuous marriage with Charlie Sheen,
the moment she realized they needed a divorce,
and adjusting to life as a single mom. However,
she has insisted that the book
isn't meant to bash her ex-husband,
and it doesn't reveal the most private
details of her life. She told Radar Online:
"I went through a whole lot and I get asked a
lot of questions about that time in my life,
so I figured I would write my story and
hopefully anyone that has been, you know,
dealing with challenges will know that
there is light at the end of the tunnel."
Richards adopted her daughter Eloise in
2011 and began raising her as a single
mom. But things changed when Richards
tied the knot with Aaron Phypers in 2018.
"We just got married."
"We're married."
He began helping Richards
raise her three daughters
and adopted Eloise when she was 7 years old.
Eloise has had some developmental delays due to a
rare disorder known as Chromosome 8, Monosomy 8p,
which is characterized by a partial deletion
of the eighth chromosome. Richards discovered
the news after she noticed Eloise wasn't
reaching milestones at the typical rate,
such as learning how to walk and talk.
During an emotional reunion on "The Real
Housewives of Beverly Hills," Richards
said that the diagnosis was hard on the
family. Despite the challenges that come
with this disorder, Richards and Phypers
have remained committed to finding the best
medical care for Eloise no matter what.
Part of Richards' transformation over the years
has been a result of plastic surgery and cosmetic
procedures. In her memoir, she explained that
she's had four breast augmentation surgeries.
Richards added that she got her first surgery at
just 19 years old because she thought her A-cup
breasts weren't big enough for Hollywood. She was
in such a rush to get the surgery that she didn't
properly research doctors, and unfortunately, she
ended up with bigger implants than she wanted.
The second surgery was meant to reduce her
breast size, but the doctor went against her
wishes and gave her even bigger implants. The
third surgery finally reduced her breast size,
and the fourth replaced the
implants after they ruptured.
She has also tried Botox, saying she loved
how the results looked but didn't like the way
they made her face feel. Since then, Richards
has been avoiding Botox and fillers. In fact,
she has claimed that she's never
used fillers. Some people thought
she did in 2019, but she says she just
gained weight due to a thyroid issue.
So, how does Richards maintain her youthful
appearance without Botox and fillers? It's simple:
She takes great care of her skin. Her passion
for skincare led her to create CBme Beauty,
a line of hemp-infused skincare products. In a
2020 interview with Us Weekly, Richards explained:
"I'm in front of the camera so I do
want to take very good care of my skin,
and that's also why I thought it would be a
great time to venture to have my own skin line."
The skincare line consists of six products,
including a hydrating cream moisturizer and eye
cream. Richards' personal favorite, she said,
is the hydrating moisturizer made with
hemp oil. In her interview with Us Weekly,
she said she plans to expand the line with new
products that contain CBD and other cannabinoids.
In 2022, Sheen and Richards' then-18-year-old
daughter Sami joined OnlyFans, a site that
allows users to sell nude photos
and videos to their subscribers.
Richards thought it was unfair that
Sami was getting so much backlash,
so a week later, she joined the site
as well to support her daughter.
"I always think it's good
for kids to have a passion."
Sheen, on the other hand, was very opposed
to his daughter joining OnlyFans. He even
blamed Richards for Sami's actions since
they were living together at the time.
Richards said that all she could do was try
to guide Sami, but at the end of the day,
she makes her own decisions. On a more positive
note, Richards said during a 2022 interview with
the radio show "Jeff Lewis Live" that making an
OnlyFans account has been very lucrative for her.
"So you were shocked when you got
your first check?"
"I was shocked."
She posts content that's a bit more
revealing than what she can post on
Instagram and said she has full ownership of
what she shares, which she finds empowering.
Richards has helped many charities over the
years. In 2006, she did a nude photoshoot for
"Jane" magazine to support the Clothes Off
Our Back Foundation, which helps children
all around the world live better lives. She
collaborated with ShoeDazzle multiple times
in 2012 to design high heels and raise
money for the Kidney Cancer Association,
successfully raising over $15,000 in the process.
She has also been a huge supporter of Best
Friends Animal Society, fostering kittens with
the help of her daughters and raising awareness
about the benefits of adopting animals. She even
paid for several rescue dogs' medical care,
nursed them back to health, and adopted them.
Richards stayed busy after leaving "The
Real Housewives of Beverly Hills" in 2020,
landing many different roles on TV shows. Perhaps
most notably, she played fun single mom Shauna
Fulton on "The Bold and the Beautiful" for several
years. In the series "Paper Empire," she portrays
a wealthy woman whose opulent lifestyle
gets turned upside-down when her husband
gets arrested. The show is set to premiere
in 2024. Richards also portrayed CIA agent
Laura Louis in "The Guardians of Justice."
Fans were disappointed when Denise Richards
left "The Real Housewives of Beverly Hills" in
Season 10, but she's officially returning to the
show for Season 13. Her return was so unexpected
that even the production crew didn't know about it
until it happened. Richards randomly showed up
at a screening because she's friends with Real
Housewife Garcelle Beauvais, and then the crew
asked her to attend some events. From there,
she started getting more involved.
Richards told Variety in 2023:
"I have filmed some episodes
and it's been fun. And you know,
I'm a big fan of the show, so it was fun to
go back and film a lot of stuff with them."
Richards has confirmed that she
won't be in Season 13's promo shots,
so it seems like she'll be returning as
a guest. There was a lot of drama and
negativity surrounding Richards' exit from
the show in 2020, but she says things were
different this time around. She told Variety
that she didn't get caught up in the drama
and had fun with the whole experience
rather than letting others get her down.